♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-President Biden returned
to the White House today
after Queen Elizabeth's funeral.
Of course,
now he's calling it his flat.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
80% of Americans said
that they have not cried about
the death of Queen Elizabeth,
while the other 20% said,
"No spoilers!"
[ Laughter ]
President Biden appeared
for an interview
on last night's episode
of "60 Minutes,"
or as it was known yesterday,
"600 Minutes."
[ Laughter ]
"I ever tell you about the time
I almost met Warren G. Harding?"
[ Laughter ]
According to new poll,
President Biden's
approval rating has hit
an 11-month high.
Wow! Inflation really is
out of control.
[ Laughter ]
Attorney General Merrick Garland
administered
the oath of allegiance
on Saturday
to 200 new U.S. citizens
during a naturalization ceremony
on Ellis Island and said,
"We must not allow the fractures
between us
to fracture our democracy,"
which must have been alarming
for the new citizens.
"Congratulations!
Enjoy it while it lasts."
[ Laughter ]
After Florida governor
Ron DeSantis sent two planes
of migrants to Martha's Vineyard
last week,
Texas governor Greg Abbott
bused dozens of migrants
to Vice President Kamala Harris'
residence in Washington, D.C.
Okay. What's going on
with these governors?
It's like we radicalized
the Impractical Jokers.
[ Laughter ]
"Okay, now go up to him
and give him a bus ticket."
[ Laughter ]
In his speech in Ohio
over the weekend,
former president Trump said
that he had a
"very luxurious
and enjoyable life"
before he entered politics.
Dude, you didn't enter politics.
You went straight to president
without even trying.
Don't make it sound like you
gave up your medical practice
to go door-to-door, campaigning
for city comptroller.
You had a nice house,
and then, for a while,
you had two nice houses.
[ Laughter ]
Two radio hosts in New Jersey
are facing criticism
after voicing support
for teachers
who have been accused of
having sex with students.
For what it's worth, the radio
hosts have issued an apology
and a genuinely remorseful
sound effect.
[ Sad trombone ]
[ Laughter ]
Kanye West announced last week
that he has terminated
his partnership with
the clothing company Gap.
Instead, he's going
with Ann Taylor Loft.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
producers have announced
that "Phantom of the Opera,"
which is the longest-running
Broadway show,
will close next year.
Said one man, "Oh, sure, right
when masks become optional."
[ Laughter ]
"I was gonna leave it on!"
President Biden claimed
in a new interview
that the coronavirus pandemic
is over.
Well, easy for him to say --
he just had it.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, it's over when
you've got the antibodies.
"I'm off to Burning Man and then
London for the Queen's funeral.
No masks. No masks."
CBS is facing criticism over
its decision to end coverage
of Queen Elizabeth's funeral
yesterday
in order to air episodes of
"Let's Make a Deal,"
and "The Price is Right."
Though, if you're a fan
of those two shows,
you've probably seen plenty
of funerals.
[ Laughter ]
That's right -- They cut away
from Queen Elizabeth's funeral
yesterday to air episodes of
"Let's Make a Deal"
and "The Price is Right,"
or as the British Empire
used to call those,
foreign policy.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump has
reportedly said
that Florida governor
Ron DeSantis stole his idea
to send migrants
to different states.
Also, his idea of
standing like it's
your first time.
[ Laughter ]
Amazon founder Jeff Bezos
recently dropped
on the Bloomberg
Billionaire Index
to the third-richest person
in the world.
He lost his spot when he bought
a Tesla.
[ Laughter ]
Former Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo spoke this morning
at the New Hampshire Institute
of Politics speaker series,
titled, "Politics and Eggs,"
I assume as one of the eggs?
[ Laughter ]
I-I assume.
It wasn't a joke.
It was an assumption.
I don't...
Pompeo criticized
President Biden
for his recent speech
attacking the MAGA movement,
and said, quote, "Treating
your countryman like enemies
is a rejection of the principles
that make America great."
Oh, so maybe they were chanting
"Hug Mike Pence."
[ Laughter ]
Tampa Bay Buccaneers
Quarterback Tom Brady apologized
on Sunday after throwing
a tablet on the sidelines.
To be fair, new technology
can be hard for boomers
to figure out.
[ Laughter ]
A lawyer in Kentucky was
recently suspended
after he allegedly offered
to help a defendant
in exchange for nude photos.
It's the rare case of a lawyer
trying to get himself off.
[ Laughter ]
Scollins? Yeah, Scollins.
And finally, Christmas is now
less than 100 days away.
Or, if you ask Costco, six.
[ Laughter ]
Well, it's Wednesday,
so it's time for Donald Trump's
crime of the week.
What is it this week?
Did he tie a lady
to some train tracks?
Did he blow up city hall?
Oh, massive tax fraud,
the old classic.
[ Laughter ]
New York attorney general
Letitia James today
filed an over-200-page
civil fraud lawsuit
against former president Trump,
several of his children,
business partners
in The Trump Organization.
I'd say he needs a good lawyer,
but that's been true
for a while now.
[ Laughter ]
In the new lawsuit filed today,
New York attorney general
Letitia James
alleges that
The Trump Organization
deceived lenders, insurers,
and tax officials
by inflating the value
of its properties.
Even worse, he listed himself
as 6'7" on his Tinder profile.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
hosted a reception today
at New York's American Museum
of Natural History,
where he also spent some time
catching up with old friends.
"Chompy!"
[ Laughter ]
"It's been ages, Chompy.
Ohh! Oh, God, no, Chompy."
[ Laughter ]
"What did they do to you,
Chompy?"
[ Laughter ]
Russia announced plans
to hold an annexation vote
in occupied portions of Ukraine.
And this is cool --
They also announced
what the results
of the vote will be.
[ Laughter ]
You don't have to stay up late.
According to the latest numbers,
Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg's
net worth
decreased this year
by more than $71 billion.
No wonder he wants to live
in the metaverse.
He can't afford a place
in San Francisco anymore.
[ Laughter ]
The 22nd annual
Congressional Basketball Game
was held on Monday night,
and the team of Congress people
beat the team of lobbyists.
Or -- just throwing this
out there -- they let you win.
[ Laughter ]
A man in Kentucky recently
set a Guinness world record
after driving a mile in reverse
in just over 75 seconds.
He then smartly refused
the breathalyzer.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, what?
I set a world record?
Alright!"
According to new survey,
3% of Americans
said that they have waited
in a line for over eight hours.
"Well, we're still not opening
a second register,"
said CVS.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, officials
from the CDC said this week
that there was a 26% rise
in syphilis infections
reported last year.
Well, good luck with that.
We couldn't even get people
to wear masks.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden addressed the
UN General Assembly yesterday
and said that the Russian
invasion of Ukraine
"is about extinguishing
Ukraine's right
to exist as a state,"
and 9 out of 10 times,
I agree we shouldn't do that.
[ Laughter ]
In the same speech,
President Biden addressed
the ongoing invasion in Ukraine
and said, "Russia has shamefully
violated the core tenets
of the United Nations Charter,
not to mention the dress code.
[ Laughter ]
Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelenskyy
addressed the
UN General Assembly yesterday
in a pre-recorded speech,
and it must have been
very pre-recorded,
'cause he said,
"Everything's great."
[ Laughter ]
The House yesterday
voted 229 to 203
to overhaul
the Electoral Count Act.
Though, somehow
that wasn't a majority.
[ Laughter ]
Always put math in the jokes.
People love to do that math.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden issued
a major disaster declaration
yesterday for Puerto Rico,
but thankfully Governor DeSantis
is already sending help.
[ Laughter ]
In an interview
on Fox News last night,
former President Trump defended
his handling
of sensitive materials
and said that he had the power
to declassify documents
"even by thinking about it."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, great.
So, on top of everything else,
Trump has The Shining.
Well...
[ Laughter ]
...that explains
his luck with hotels.
[ Laughter ]
In the same interview,
former President Trump claimed
that the agents who raided
his Mar-a-Lago home
took his will and said it could
"cause a lot of problems
if it's published,"
'cause not everyone
made the cut.
[ Laughter ]
A banner was raised
in Madison Square Garden
last night celebrating...
[ Women cheering ]
[ Laughter ]
Get it out of your system.
He's not here.
[ Laughter ]
He's not gonna see this.
He's not gonna know you cheered.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
And, by the way, buddy,
if you are watching,
I'm so sorry I said that.
We'd love to have you.
If you're in your hotel
after a concert right now
relaxing with "Late Night"
and you just saw that joke,
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean it, buddy.
[ Laughter ]
A banner was raised
in Madison Square Garden
last night celebrating
Harry Styles'
15 nights of concerts.
"Plenty of room up there,"
said Knicks fans.
[ Laughter ]
World champs -- 1973.
Harry Styles.
[ Laughter ]
Today was the first day of fall,
and due to climate change, this
is how the leaves are changing.
That was taken in Vermont.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
Taco Bell has announced
that it will begin testing
its new meatless carne asada
next month at dozens
of locations in Dayton, Ohio,
raising the question --
how many Taco Bells
does Dayton, Ohio, need?
[ Laughter ]
But true story --
I tried to book a flight
to Dayton today
after I heard this news,
and they were available.
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody!